I'm you know overwhelmed but I've I also
want a big award and a couple of minor
things and I I'm trying to just keep in
mind that this is just a blip you know
in my life I mean if I get it that'll be
very nice and probably lead to a flurry
of emails and phone calls and who knows
maybe some trips and then it'll all be
over and the big spotlight will move on
to somebody else and my studio will
become very quiet again and it's that's
that's just the way it goes and that's a
good thing
I do not believe that it was
miscategorized i think it was
categorized exactly where it should be I
didn't think of categories when I was
writing the book I knew that I was
stepping out of the children's world but
I never thought that I was stepping
completely into the adult world because
the book is about a teenager for example
it really the principal ages are 6 and
14 the main character and I women when
the controversy started I began having
second thoughts and wondering hmm that I
put some things in there that you know
teenagers couldn't handle I didn't think
so I mean they see so much now and
things are talked about so openly and in
young adult literature I actually
thought that I was being rather modest
in my book with the things that I left
out and also by not taking by not
adopting a totally sarcastic viewpoint
that I questioned myself about that too
because it almost seemed totally uncool
to to not be you know absolutely ironic
about everything I'm not really ironic
about anything in this book it's pretty
sincere without I hope ever falling into
sentimentality which I despise but I I
you know I was questioning it until
yesterday at the New York Public Library
where the five of us finalists spoke to
a room of I don't know it looked like
hundreds of teenagers and they all came
up to the mics afterwards with questions
and I could see that these young people
were so touched by stitches i was there
was just unbelievable it was the
questions that they asked were they were
the equal of the very best questions
that i have been asked by bloggers in
the hole you know you can read 53
pages of blogs and reviews of my book on
google + and these kids were just as
intelligent and just as they were giving
my book just as sensitive a read as any
adult who's talked to me and I I was
really touched by that and as one of the
teachers said to me who came up to the
table afterwards you know everybody
feels especially at this age they feel
the kind of isolation that that's talked
about in stitches they feel that that
kind of loneliness and I you know the
book is really it's not about it is not
about being an abused child in the sense
of the kind of abuse that attracts our
attention in newspapers all the time you
know kids getting their limbs broken and
being thrown down stairs or out of
second-floor windows that none of that
happened to me I was abused but it was
all psychological it was much subtler
and I think everyone to some extent can
relate to that and I think above all why
this is a book for teenagers is that
teenagers part of the teenage angst part
of the part of the hawks teenis of being
a teenager and part of the rebellion is
that this sense that they're not being
told everything about the adult world
that there's a that there's a deep
hypocrisy out there that they are
desperate to know about and you know
teenagers are always sneaking around in
drawers where they shouldn't go and
reading things they shouldn't be reading
and and that's an attempt to try I think
to penetrate and that actually happens
in my book there's that's how I found
out as a teenager what was going on but
was by sneaking into drawers and reading
letters that I had no business reading
this is how I found out that I had had
cancer that everybody my whole family
thought that I was going to die and
nobody had told me about it
and my reaction at the time was the
reaction that I had been taught by my
own family to give which was to clam up
to not respond to hold it inside and
then when I started like a teenager will
to act out and in pretty bad ways
running away from school and threatening
suicide and needing to see a shrink and
so on that's when that's when the truth
began to come out and and of course what
I discovered on my own was that you know
that I'd had cancer but then I found out
later that it was my dad who had given
it to me as in his in his practice as a
radiologist and and that was just the
sort of the tip of the iceberg in terms
of mixed metaphors family skeletons you
know that was the least of the ones that
came tumbling out of the closet one
after another at that point so I think
this is something that kids really
really can relate to and I don't see it
miscategorized it on and very happy to
be in that category